die suche nach maria kann escada geht
weiter gestern soll die
oppositionsführerin in weißrussland
verschleppt worden seien jetzt gibt es
andere quellen jedoch die behaupten sie
sei ausgereist und zwar in die ukraine
darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
bild vize franz immer bei mir und uns
auch zugeschaltet direkt aus
weißrussland sergej paul gibt es jetzt
schon überhaupt irgendwelche gesicherten
aussagen darüber was mit maria kann ich
da passiert ist
es gibt von ihr persönlich stand jetzt
keine stellungnahme auch nicht dass im
umfeld allerdings gibt es ein statement
des ukrainischen vize innenministers der
sagt dass ihre mitstreiter die grenze
überquert haben und sie soll beim
versuch offenbar der weißrussischen
behörden sie abzuschieben mehr oder
weniger ihren pass zerrissen haben das
sagen zwei unabhängige quellen in dem
fall zumindest unabhängig von
weißrussischen start
und tatsächlich sieht es so aus dass das
momentan der stand ist das heißt sie ist
nicht entführt worden
doch sie ist für verschleppt worden in
weißrussland am tag zuvor auf diesen
bildern die wir dort auch gesehen haben
also in dem bus offenbar weg
transportiert man weiß nicht wo sie sich
von gestern morgen bis in der nacht
aufgehalten hat offenbar so sieht es
momentan aus war sie in den händen des
geheimdienstes und sollte dann zusammen
mit ihren mitstreitern in die ukraine
abgeschoben werden und bei diesem
versuch der weißrussischen behörden sie
abzuschieben soll ihr pass soll sie
selbst ihren pass zerrissen haben um in
belarus bleiben zu können das ist der
stand den wir momentan haben das ist das
was der vize innenminister der ukraine
sagt und das ist auch das was
unabhängige weißrussische medien melden
allerdings es gibt kein offizielles
statement bislang von weißrussischen
behörden von lukaschenko von den
sicherheitsbehörden dort wie genau war
die reaktion in weißrussland als gestern
bekannt geworden ist dass die
oppositionsführerin verschleppt worden
sein soll
das war zum einen gegen führung weil wir
natürlich
empört sind so dass so eine frau die
immer friedlich war die nie zu protesten
aufgerufen hat die nur mit bekommen ist
die protestler unterstützt aber nicht
dazu aufgerufen habe jetzt auch so
gewaltsame weise entführt worden ist
zum anderen aber hier ist das ja wir
können eine oppositionsführern abführen
aber die können nicht die proteste
dadurch irgendwie zunichte machen die
menschen werden nach wie vor standhaft
bleiben und auch die straßen gehen weil
das was jetzt auch die schaumbildung see
das ist der stand also jeder von uns
will dass lukaschenko geht und da
brauchen wir keinen anführer um das
offen und fröhlich zusammen
muss man denn sagen dass solche
verschleppungen oder entführungen etwas
sind was man in weißrussland leider
bereits kennt von der opposition das
also dass die opposition opfer solch ein
führungen wird absolut richtig im
augenblick ist der stand so dass wir
alle kennen den fall von sind daher von
der frau die zur präsidentin gewählt
worden ist da dass sie auf solche weise
nach litauen angeschoben wurde dann eine
weiteres mitglied des koordinationsrates
und in kuba ist so nach polen
wegtransportiert davor waren sie auch
einige tage also man wusste nicht wo sie
sich befinden das heißt das können wir
leider in den letzten tagen und den
letzten wochen immer besser sei gerade
von paul gehört es wird gesagt da ist
kurzzeitig ein anderer kollege sage wir
haben gerade schon gehört sie soll ihren
pass jetzt zerrissen haben an der grenze
was für information hat man in
weißrussland jetzt darüber was genau
sich an der grenze abgespielt hat zur
ukraine
wie baut die richtig gesagt hat es gibt
sie immer noch keine offiziellen
meldungen von denn weder wusste schon
von den weißrussischen
sicherheitsbehörden das grants komitee
die grenzbehörden sagt ja maria galenica
wurde festgenommen bei dem versuch
ausweis muss man zu verlieren so nennt
man das
sondern dass hier die offizielle stimme
aber es gibt keine weiteren angaben um
der rechtsanwalt kann immer noch nicht
da seine mandantin treffen das ist auch
der standort den wert
wir sehen jetzt gerade die karte den
grenzübergang wo es zu diesen szenen
gekommen sein soll
gibt es da besonderheiten wo genau liegt
das was kannst du uns über diese orte
sagen
das ist tiefe provinz das ist im
südosten des landes nicht weiter von dem
verseuchten gebiet verseuchte durch ihre
kontaminierte durch die explosion in
tschernobyl kraft wehrt aber an sich ist
es nur ein übergang geben so weit weg in
der provinz wo keine großstadt in sich
in der nähe befindet diejenigen die
maria und ihre mitstreiter abschieden
wollten wohl keinen protest und sagen
wir keine fremden augen haben
also muss man sagen als
sicherheitsbehörde kann man da recht
unbeobachtet agieren wenn man
tatsächlich eine oppositionsführerin
verschleppt hat und diese dann aus dem
land bringen möchte natürlich richtig
wohl wirklich sorgen dank sergej für den
moment paul sag uns doch was genau hat
das jetzt für eine politische bedeutung
auch für deutschland für die jung was
muss jetzt passieren
es hat eine große politische brisanz was
dort passiert ist weil maria callas nica
ich selbst habe sie mehrfach getroffen
zu interviews über sehr präsent in den
deutschen medien insgesamt aber auch
international immer dann wenn über die
proteste berichtet wurde hat man sie an
vorderster front gesehen vor den komoren
sicherheitskräften sie ist die
furchtlose frau und wenn es stimmt was
dort passiert ist dass sie tatsächlich
ihren pass zerrissen hat und
möglicherweise jetzt festgenommen wird
dann wird sie natürlich zu so etwas
wieder helden in der weissrussischen
oppositionsbewegung denn diesen mut muss
man erst einmal haben dann wenn man
abgeschoben werden soll vor den augen
von den sicherheitskräften ein pass zu
zerreißen zu sagen nein ich bleibe hier
ich kämpfe weiter für die freiheit und
das sollte dann auch natürlich ein
signal an die europäische öffentlichkeit
sein und ein signal dass wir etwas tun
dass deutschland etwas tut dass die
kanzlerin etwas tut und der
außenminister etwas tun das ist bislang
so sagen auch viele in der bewegung
bislang zu wenig gewesen an
unterstützung aber möglicherweise ist
lukas schinko hier einen schritt zu weit
gegangen und ist hat tatsächlich
konsequenzen allerdings muss man sagen
wenn man sich die vergangenen wochen
anschaut dann wird es immer schwieriger
für die proteste lukaschenko unterdrückt
und die unterstützung von putin bedeutet
dass er sich stand jetzt im amt halten
kann ist er gerade gesagt wenn sie die
tatsächlichen pass zerrissen hat ist sie
jetzt
genommen worden du warst jetzt lange für
uns in minsk und hass gesehen was mit
den demonstranten passiert ist die
festgenommen worden sind das sind
schreckliche zustände sie wurden
gefoltert geschlagen wie gefährlich ist
diese situation dann für sie die
situation für maria ist brandgefährlich
ich habe ihr vor zwei stunden wieder
eine telegramm nachricht geschrieben das
ist wie man mit ihr kommuniziert das ist
sozusagen der sichere kanal und ich habe
mir geschrieben wir bei bild wir denken
ganz fest an sie und wir hoffen dass sie
unversehrt ist und dass sie es schafft
wieder in freiheit zu kommen
ich glaube dass man sie aus dem spiel
nehmen wollte weil sie bekannter
geworden ist weil sie das sympathische
offene gesichter opposition geworden ist
und weil man rhetorisch nichts gegen sie
anrichten konnte
denn selbst wenn ich sie gefragt habe
was denken sie über sanktionen was ist
mit russland da hat sie sich sehr
zurückgehalten sie hat gesagt unser ziel
ist dass das belarussische volk
lukaschenko los wird dass der diktator
geht wir wollen eigentlich gar nicht
dass sich die mächte von außen also dass
sich russland europa einmischen
sie sagt wir wollten das als volk
schaffen wir wollen dass als folge
schaffen und ich glaube deswegen war sie
für lukaschenko und ist sie für
lukaschenko so gefährlich mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren